merci bonjour bonjour à tous ce que nous
constatons c'est une aggravation de
cette crise migratoire très préoccupante
à laquelle l'europe et la france doivent
faire face quelques mots d'abord sur les
récents développements
la décision qui vient d'être prise par
la chancelière merkel décision qui
consiste à rétablir provisoirement des
contrôles à la frontière autrichienne
cette décision de madame merkel valide
très exactement
l'analyse qui est celle du président
nicolas sarkozy
je voudrais rappeler à cet égard que dès
2008 nicolas sarkozy a été le leader
européen engageant les états membres de
l'union européenne dans la négociation
et la définition du pacte européen sur
l'immigration et l'asile qui donc en
2008 adoptée à l'unanimité par les états
membres avaient été le socle d'une
politique d'immigration commune
c'était en 2008 la france jusqu'en 2012
avait pris d'autres initiatives nicolas
sarkozy en 2011 comme président de la
république avait appelé à des évolutions
droit de l'immigration et avait appelé
notamment dès 2011 à ce qu'il puisse
être possible de rétablir un contrôle
aux frontières en cas de crise
migratoire
mais depuis 2012
les dirigeants français ou en tout cas
ceux qui font semblant de diriger la
france qui font semblant de gouverner
n'ont pris aucune initiative en ce sens
et au fond on peut dire que ils ne sont
pas passés du pacte aux actes du pacte
européen de 2008
à des actes permettant à une nouvelle
politique européenne d'immigration de se
mettre en place et ce qui se passe ces
dernières semaines valide très
exactement l'analyse du président
sarkozy qui démontre par la sa capacité
d'anticipation et son leadership
oui nous pensons qu'il faut s'engager
urgemment dans une vraie refondation de
schengen
le système schengen tel qu'il fonctionne
précisément ne fonctionne plus il faut
le refonder de manière extrêmement
déterminé en remettant les choses dans
l'ordre
si j'ose dire très concrètement
aujourd'hui nous pensons que la france
doit prendre l'initiative de rétablir
provisoirement à la frontière franco
italienne des contrôles aux frontières
est donc très concrètement nous pensons
qu'à la frontière franco italienne
compte tenu de l'afflux qui existent en
provenance du sud qui se dirige
notamment vers le calaisis nous pensons
qu'il est nécessaire aujourd'hui de
procéder à des contrôles sous la forme
opérationnelle de patrouilles mobiles de
la police aux frontières
nous pensons aussi président sarkozy l'a
dit dans son interview du figaro jeudi
dernier et l'a rappelé manière très
claire dans son discours du touquet nous
pensons tout à fait nécessaire de
progresser vers un statut de réfugié de
guerre à partir du droit existant et là
dessus je veux souligner l'ignorance la
triple ignorance qui est celle du
gouvernement gouvernement a déclaré il
ya quelques jours que le statut de
réfugié de guerre il n'en avait jamais
entendu parler nous appelons le
gouvernement et notamment l'hôtel
matignon a peut-être un peu mieux
préparés au plan technique certain
nombre d'annoncés politique et une
triple ignorant si l ignorance de la
directive de 2001
très précisément la directive 2001 55
juillet 2001 qui définit ce qu'on
appelle une protection temporaire en cas
d'afflux massif de personnes déplacées
directive de 2001
cette directive de 2001 elle a été
transposée en droit français par la loi
du 24 juillet 2006 est donc très
précisément aujourd'hui dans le code de
l'entrée et du séjour des étrangers et
du droit d'asile
c'est à dire dans la loi française il
existe des articles qui prévoit très
précisément ce statut de protection
temporaire seconde ignorance semble-t-il
du gouvernement 3e ignorance du
gouvernement depuis 2003 depuis une loi
de décembre 2003 il existe dans le code
de l'entrée et du séjour et du droit
d'asile ceseda ce qu'on appelle la
protection subsidiaire et c'est très
exactement ce que le président sarkozy
désigne lorsqu'il évoque la nécessité
d'aménager un statut de réfugié de
guerre c'est à dire l'accueil temporaire
d'un certain nombre de personnes qui
sont visés par des conflits armés
internes aux internationaux l'accueil
provisoire pendant la durée de ce
conflit et jusqu'à ce que la paix
revienne sommes très étonnés ici que le
gouvernement soit à ce point ignorants
de la loi de la république française et
des normes européennes
ce statut de réfugié de guerre doit être
utilisée parce que nous ne voulons pas
que soit organisé le transfert et
l'installation durable en france d'une
partie de la population du moyen-orient
c'est vrai pour les syriens
c'est vrai pour les irakiens c'est vrai
notamment parmi eux pour les chrétiens
d'orient l'avenir des syriens dans la
durée doit être dans une scierie en paix
l'avenir des chrétiens d'orient doit
être dans la durée bien sûr en orient ce
sera un appauvrissement terrible pour
lorient que de perdre toute présence
vivante
des chrétiens est donc ce statut de
réfugié de guerre
qu'il s'agisse de la protection
temporaire ou de la protection
subsidiaire
ce statut de réfugié de guerre il doit
être utilisé
nous pensons aussi enfin que toutes les
questions doivent être mises sur la
table à bruxelles et il faut que la
france soit à l'initiative françois
hollande depuis des mois fait ce qu'il
sait faire c'est-à-dire pas grand-chose
il obéit aux propositions qui sont
celles de monsieur juncker
il change d'avis il était contre les
quotas d'asile et pour semble-t-il il
totalement perdu aurait aucune capacité
d'anticipation qu'une vision aucun
leadership ce que nous pensons donc
c'est qu'il faut une refondation de
schengen
des contrôles provisoire aux frontières
c'est clair notamment en ce qui nous
concerne à la frontière franco-italienne
une vraie utilisation de ce statut de
réfugié de guerre avec des centres de
rétention internationaux prêts de la
zone irako syrienne qui reste à créer
et pour cela il faut une vraie
initiative française une initiative euro
méditerranéenne il faut une initiative
politique au plus haut niveau pour créer
cela et pour éviter que les candidats au
statut de réfugié ou de réfugiés de
guerre traversent la méditerranée au
péril de leur vie donc il faut une
initiative très forte
et puis il faudra aussi une refondation
totale des différents instruments de la
politique d'immigration à cet égard et
je vais m'arrêter là
nous vous donnons rendez vous mercredi
mercredi 16 septembre nous organisons
ici au siège des républicains une
journée de travail qui est ouverte à la
presse qui est aussi naturellement
ouverte à l'ensemble des parlementaires
membres du bureau politique du comité
exécutif avait des différentes instances
des républicains tout le monde
naturellement est invité ceux qui sont
spécialisés un peu au parlement sur la
question migratoire mais aussi
l'ensemble de nos responsables et de nos
parlementaires
donc la journée commence à 8h30 elle
sera introduite bien sûr par eric woerth
qui est le délégué général au projet co
animée par françois noël buffet sénateur
secrétaire nationale à l'immigration
avec avec moi et nous aurons trois
tables rondes
une première table ronde que j'animerai
et qui sera consacrée au fonds un
échange sur le constat un constat
partagé en 2015 la france est confrontée
à un défi migratoire dans un certain
nombre d'experts de cette maison mais
aussi de l'extérieur qui viendront
échanger on aurait une deuxième table
ronde qui sera animée par roger
karoutchi sénateur des hauts-de-seine
qui est le rapporteur au sénat de toutes
les questions qu'ils tiennent à l'azile
notamment sur l'ong budgétaire on
évoquera dans cette deuxième table ronde
au fond comme on dit du benchmarking
c'est à dire des expériences européennes
d'autres états membres notamment
et puis on aura une troisième plus
opérationnels qui évoquera les
évolutions et les ruptures qui nous
paraissent nécessaires au fond pour
redonner aux français le droit de
choisir qui ils souhaitent accueillir en
france et qui souhaitent refusé en
france puisque au fond c'est ça la
question de fond comment retrouver la
capacité d'action pour choisir qui nous
souhaitons accueillir dans notre pays
cette journée de travail sera conclu par
le président des républicains nicolas
sarkozy en fin de matinée j'ajoute que
le président dans sa campagne
d'élection pour devenir le président de
notre famille politique avait pris un
engagement qui est celui de donner la
parole aux adhérents du mouvement cet
engagement bien sûr sera sera tenu
et ces questions d'immigration qui sont
absolument majeur pour l'avenir de notre
pays
comme vous le voyez on les prend ici
très très très directement faut pas
avoir peur de les aborder
parce que ce sont des questions qui se
posent et d'ailleurs vous me permettrez
une remarque alors que le gouvernement
et le parti socialiste nous disait qu'au
fond il ya un débat interdit qu'on doit
pas parler d'immigration
on constate que comme par hasard le jour
où les républicains décident d'organiser
une journée de travail et de débats sur
l'immigration
à 15 heures le même jour à l'assemblée
nationale le premier ministre décide de
s'exprimer sur le même sujet ce qui
prouve peut-être que en effet il s'agit
bien d'un sujet d'extrême importance
abordé sans tabou très directement avec
des propositions opérationnelles en tout
cas c'est ce que nous efforçons de faire
ici rue de vaugirard est partout en
france
merci guillaume pour ce développement
sur sur la question des migrants et de
l'immigration de manière plus générale
nous allons passer à l'agenda de la
semaine donc aujourd'hui à 16h15 nicolas
sarkozy s'entretient avec joseph daul
qui est le président du parti populaire
européen pour évoquer tous les sujets
liés donc à la crise des migrants et aux
réfugiés mardi à 10 heures conférence de
presse présentation de proposition de
loi relative à la régionalisation de
l'apprentissage avec les chefs de file
républicains aux élections régionales
cette conférence de presse a lieu ici
est 10h45 le président nicolas sarkozy
participera à la réunion du groupe l'est
républicain à l'assemblée nationale
mercredi comme l'a évoqué guillaume
larrivé donc journée de travail sur sur
la politique d'immigration
donc il y aura du public et elle est
ouverte aux journalistes à 11h au
réunion autour de nicolas sarkozy et des
chefs de file républicains aux
régionales puis à 17h commission
exécutif jeudi à 19 heures nicolas
sarkozy sera présent comité
départemental des républicains des
hauts-de-seine et vendredi le président
se réunit avec des maires de
l'association des maires de france le
comité des mères avec françois baroin
hubert falco et jean rottner pour
discuter des différents problèmes qu'ont
les collectivités aujourd'hui notamment
le problème de la dotation aux
collectivités qui a été réduite de
manière drastique le besoin de dialogue
qu'ont également les élus avec avec avec
le siège avec d'autres responsables
alors bonne nouvelle pour les
républicains la législative qui a eu
lieu dans l'aveyron qui encore une fois
comme donc valide la stratégie de
nicolas sarkozy et des républicains
puisque cette législative et et
victorieuse pour les républicains
arnaud viala donc devient député de
l'aveyron avec 63 49 % des suffrages
face aux socialistes qui n'obtient que
36 de 51% donc une progression de plus
de 10 points sur sur une terre qui
étaient traditionnellement à gauche donc
notre notre stratégie de conquête
fonctionne nous avons grâce à nicolas
sarkozy de nombreuses victoires depuis
son retour à la tête du parti et
l'alternance et est en route et je pense
que nous prouverons encore une fois lors
du scrutin de décembre
ici merci lydia donc cette semaine nous
avons droit comme ça a commencé il y à
il ya quelques semaines aux
déambulations de françois hollande
françois hollande qui s'était pendant
une partie du quinquennat bunkerisé à
l'elysée a décidé d'en sortir puisque
maintenant il est désormais personne ne
l'ignorent en campagne électorale pour
les élections présidentielles de 2017
avec un petit accent particulier à l'
approche des élections régionales
donc nous avons eu droit à la
déambulation de françois hollande eux au
zoo de beauval le vendredi et cette
semaine nous avons droit à un comité
interministériel à vesoul sur la
ruralité
alors on est bien évidemment la proche
des élections régionales dans la
manipulation la plus totale nous avions
eu droit
souvenez vous au mois de mars ça devait
être le 10 ou le 11 mars à la même chose
dans l'aisne
un comité interministériel s'était pas
françois hollande s'était manuel valls
pour nous parler de ruralité on nous
avait promis que croit bois croix de fer
il y allait avoir un certain nombre de
propositions importantes pour la
ruralité finalement ça n'a débouché sur
rien et la preuve aujourd'hui c'est que
ça n'a débouché sur rien puisque on
commence on reprend j'allais dire les
mêmes et on recommence
sur le même thème de la ruralité donc la
volonté d'aller chercher les voix de la
ruralité pour les élections régionales
eh bien ça avait été la même
manipulation pour les élections
départementales en mars dernier mais je
prends les paris
le résultat de la première manipulation
dans l'aisne
ç'avait été une vague bleue aux
élections départementales le monde rural
ne s'était pas laissé berner et bien je
prends le pari que à nouveau le monde
rural ne se laissera pas berner pour les
élections régionales avec ce comité
interministériel à vesoul et pour la
première fois d'ailleurs un comité
interministériel va être présidée par le
président de la république ce qu'il ne
se fait jamais et par ailleurs on nous
promet de s'occuper du monde du monde
rural
mais il n'y aura personne au salon des
éleveurs de rennes savez le space de
rennes qui a lieu chaque année et bien
devait recevoir manuel valls en personne
qui s'est décommandé est donc
aujourd'hui
eh bien nous savons qu'il n'y aura aucun
membre du gouvernement à l'occasion de
ce salon
comme quoi la préoccupation du
gouvernement et du président de la
république pour l'arrêt rue les la
ruralité n'est qu'une nouvelle et énième
opération de communication alors puisque
nous parlons de communication nous en
tant que formation politique
eh bien nous communiquons et nous
sortons pour dénoncer le gouvernement et
françois hollande l'action du
gouvernement et françois hollande nous
sortons à 300000 exemplaires
un tract que je pense vous avez sur vos
tables chômage impôts dette
hollande épuise la france nous aurions
pu mettre une laisse beaucoup plus
importante des méfaits du gouvernement
et de françois hollande mais il n'y
avait pas suffisamment de place sur le
tract donc nous avons pris ce que les
français aient bien constate chaque jour
les le chômage qui bat des records de
mois en mois les impôts qui ont augmenté
plus de 50 milliards d'euros et la dette
qui galope donc nos militants
distribueront ce tract ainsi qu'un autre
tract est également édité
à 300000 exemplaires tout commence avec
vous puisque les républicains sont
ouverts sur la société sur les français
donc nous appelons eh bien les français
qui partagent nos valeurs à venir nous
rejoindre et il y aura également 40
mille affiches celle que vous voyez au
fond de la salle chômage impôts des taux
longs depuis la france qui sera édité à
40000 exemplaires et donc que les
militants mettront aux quatre coins de
notre de notre beau pays